the Joe Rogan experience as a young
church stuff from Artie or whatever it's
called uit yeah is that the Russian it's
a different no what's the Russian thing
that started all that propaganda against
that's internet research agency the IRA
against who
5g where they were saying like five g's
bad for you did you that yeah did that I
think so man
the five G [ __ ] like that propaganda is
and scary interesting it starts very
article it says Artie no Artie has been
sowing disinformation so Artie has been
so yes they're the ones that started all
this [ __ ] because I guess it's your
house I've G phone won't hurt you but
Russia wants you to think otherwise okay
a network known for salt sowing
disinformation has a new alarm the
coming
5g apocalypse who is this New York Times
yeah yeah it's interesting he said New
York Times because in New York Times if
they're printing something like that's
one of the places that are kind of site
if they're saying it it's probably true
didn't you see what they did to genk
Genki ogre from The Young Turks he was
interviewing David Duke and he goes of
course you're not a racist mocking
mocking him and they took it out of
context in quotes and they wrote that he
said to David Duke of course you're not
a racist they try to pretend somebody
just got to woke for their own good
somebody cross the line they crossed the
line they want to stop him they wanted
to stop him and so they got over woke
they lied that's crazy that's a crazy
lie though for that to get into the New
York Times I wonder what the fallout
from that was cuz that's for them that's
got to be very embarrassing that someone
actually printed that they were forced
to make a retraction but the problem
with that is when people hear about
stuff like that it you know there's a
lot of people obviously working at the
New York Times a lot of people so it
doesn't represent everybody there but
when someone gets away with something
sneaky like that it really [ __ ] over
everybody else because then all the
other people that are making stories
people gonna go yeah you're the [ __ ]
people who said that jankura said you
know David Duke wasn't a racist when
that's clearly not what he said
your [ __ ] magazines fake news it's
all
[ __ ] you're the [ __ ] newspaper
congratulations you're gonna fuel that
and the New York Times used to have none
of that right at least have none of that
should a correction that doesn't mean
anything I don't see anything else from
that if the corrections too late it's in
a newspaper
how many Corrections a a year do they it
is what I would like to know well how
many people read the correction versus
read the original story that's what gets
real weird like if you make something up
about someone then put it down or make
something interpret it incorrectly on
purpose intentionally and then you put
it out there how much of a
responsibility does the newspaper have
but how much of responsibility does that
writer have for doing that they probably
don't like him they don't want him to do
it they figure like look I [ __ ] this
guy let's just he [ __ ] said it did he
actually say it he did say it I don't
know what he meant do you know what he
meant
I [ __ ] print it I don't know I don't
know what the process was but yeah I
can't do that if you want us to take you
seriously but there's still one of that
number one oh yes I take him seriously
most of the time it's a term there was
another one they did with Conor McGregor
back when Conor McGregor fought Floyd
and they said his face was bloody didn't
know it wasn't he didn't have any blood
you guys are making things up you can't
make things up did they retract that
yeah they did you said it they did but
they had to everybody saw it
you know the arrogance that you have to
have to pretend that you saw something
that wasn't there or either that or
you're paying attention so loosely
before you write this story you don't
even give a [ __ ] out if I went ain't
gonna report in the fight you're gonna
stop you're the New York Times you're
not a podcast get a podcast website and
spread misinformation and talk stupid
[ __ ] that's the difference like nobody
takes us seriously they take the [ __ ]
New York Times seriously you have to you
got a serious job okay it's like if
you're a cop you know you got a serious
job you're a reporter reporting the
actual news got a serious job because
you can you can change the way people
look at things and it might be a lie and
that's that got us into a lot of
problems in the past
people always think they know better
though they know better than what
everybody else wants that's that's where
it's a real problem you think you're
doing good by withholding information or
you think you're doing good by censoring
people to get your news mostly for him
like Twitter or something I don't get my
news from anywhere anymore I feel great
I looked at a newspaper the other day I
picked it up and I'm like what happened
over there mm-hmm
I forget what it was about it was a
story about something and I was like I
didn't know that I read into it a little
bit was in The Wall Street Journal I was
like I got other [ __ ] to think about
it's a terribly irresponsible way to
look at things but it's a clear I don't
know I don't know if you can do that
much I don't know what the
responsibility is like ultimately to
completely pay attention to everything
all the time I don't know what
responsibility you have people get mad
at you if you don't completely take pay
attention to everything that's of
importance all the time and they had a
point
they have a point but you also have a
point for like self management and for
mental management to probably pay
attention to less [ __ ] I feel like a I
feel healthier and happier when I pay
attention to less [ __ ] so where this
Iran thinks you got me [ __ ] up because
if something makes me think about it
that means it's in the forefront of the
news now it's like big it's a big deal
I'm like oh
[Applause]